libertarians favor an aggressive what
you'd even might call an activist
judiciary one that's willing to strike
down misguided precedent overturn
unconstitutional laws conservatives
embrace judicial restraint which is the
idea that the court should be deferring
to the will of legislative majorities
deferring to the courts in upholding
laws
hi I'm Nicolas b4 recent TV today we're
talking with Damon root author of the
great July cover story and reason
conservatives versus libertarians the
debate over judicial activism divides
former allies Damon thanks for talking
to us what's what's the main beef of
your story basically it's about a
profound division within the
conservative legal movement between
libertarians and conservatives over what
the proper role of the court should be
so libertarians favor an aggressive what
you'd even might call an activist
judiciary one that's willing to strike
down misguided precedent overturn
unconstitutional laws conservatives
embrace judicial restraint which is the
idea that the court should be deferring
to the will of legislative majorities
deferring to the courts and upholding
laws and libertarians of course believe
that the court should be a check against
the tyranny of the majority
conservatives embrace this majority who
are the major players on the Supreme
Court right now who best embodied this
tension I think it's best embodied
between justices Thomas and Scalia and
of course these justices are all of two
minds on these things they're drawing
from both traditions
what's a paradigmatic example of
Clarence Thomas being you know a
hardcore libertarian legal theorist well
this is just this very week we had the
the Second Amendment case Fourteenth
Amendment case McDonald vs Chicago where
it's Justice Thomas who followed what
was the libertarian argument which was
that to apply the Second Amendment to
the states you do that through the
privileges or immunities Clause of the
Fourteenth Amendment
Justice Scalia basically who's billed
himself as his gradle originalist you
should be following the text of the
Constitution he basically ignores the
text and history of the Constitution of
the 14th amendment and just as Thomas is
the one who takes what we could call the
libertarian line right and Scalia then
is the the kind of concept or the
conservative heavyweight on the court
what's a what's a another example where
he said you know what even if this does
violate somebody's Liberty we should go
with the you know what the precedents
that are in place well in five years ago
in the medical marijuana case Gonzales v
Raich this is a case it turns on what's
the what's what is the commerce power of
the of the federal government or
Congress to regulate under the Commerce
Clause and Scalia had been this great
critic of an expansive reading of the
Commerce Clause
but then in this case maybe because it
has to do with medical marijuana or
illegal drugs something that maybe he's
uncomfortable with he suddenly his sort
of pull starts pulling back from what
had been his a more principled position
and that's also I believe it was Thomas
who said look if the Commerce Clause is
covering the potential for a state to
legalize medical marijuana provided by
non profit people then the Commerce
Clause causes it covers everything and
we're living in a total tyranny that's
he says that if this is you know
basically growing a plant in your
backyard or your neighbor grows it and
then you consume that plant on your
property it never literally never leaves
the state doesn't believe your County if
that's interstate commerce than anything
is interstate commerce in Congress can
do anything that was and of course
Scalia was following what a
depression-era
ruling that basically said that about
corn or about vegetable produce that was
created for a farmer's own personal
right it was a it was during a New Deal
Wickard versus filburn Roscoe filburn
this farmer he's growing wheat on his
own farm for his family's consumption
and to and just not to enter this stream
of Interstate Commerce at all and the
court says no no that's affects the
stream of Interstate Commerce therefore
we can regulate that and that's the
precedent that Scalia polls what do you
think is going to happen in terms of
this conservative libertarian split or
individual rights versus originalism or
I guess a deference to legislators and
precedent what what's going to happen I
think that what we're seeing is a
gradual increase of the libertarian
argument that more conservatives are
starting to be selectively libertarian
to favor a more aggressive judiciary on
some issues not at all and is that
simply because the laws they're gonna be
dealing with have been put into place by
Democrats liberals there's absolutely a
bit of whoever's in power suddenly when
you're out of power you want the courts
to strike down laws and then when you're
in power you want the courts to hold
them and I think there's there's
definitely some of that going on but
there's also I think been an
intellectual triumph of the principled
activist case that libertarians have
been making and they've been attacking
particularly judge Robert Bork who I
argue in the article is the is the most
influential conservative thinker and the
biggest advocate of this majoritarian
restraint
you know they should basically the
majority should be able to pass whatever
laws them right in his book the tempting
of America he writes that in wide areas
of life majorities are entitled to rule
if they wish simply because their
majorities he calls that the first
principle of the American system so
unlike libertarians who would say the
first principle is individual rights or
liberty Bork says its majority rule
how do liberals interface with that
because you know I mean you can see
certainly in the past they were you know
they're the reason Bork didn't make it
to the Supreme Court but do they
actually find a lot to to dig into in
terms of majoritarianism especially if
it destroys the bulwark against the
state saying hey now we're gonna start
doing this I think that that liberals
well it's interesting is this this idea
of judicial restraint and
majoritarianism is a Progressive Era
concept so it's basically pioneered by
Justice Louis Brandeis justice Oliver
Wendell Holmes and so so Bork is
essentially adopted what at one point
was a progressive legal mind set because
the progressives what they were
concerned about were conservative judges
striking down economic regulations
saying what they did during the at some
point during the the New Deal and then
they got whipped and they started giving
it up and and so what you see after the
New Deal is the Liberals who had been
arguing for judicial restraint then
start to say well but maybe we'd like
the courts to enforce some rights for
what they call us insular minorities you
start to you see this gradual well then
maybe it gets into privacy and abortion
right so suddenly the the liberal
justices start to pull back a little
from the restraint they still say let's
defer to majorities when it comes to
economic regulations but when it comes
to some rights that we value then you
should be a little more or any of the
liberal justices articulating explicitly
Burkean notions of majority they're
drawing from it and justice Stevens
particularly in the last I'd say year or
so has really started to use some of
these yeah he's obviously not citing
will he he maybe said he's not setting
Bork explicitly but I'm he's definitely
drawing on unstuff some of those
precedents that Bork would draw on and
has been accusing in the Citizens United
case in Heller and and McDonald Stevens
accused the conservative majority of
being judicial activists basically
throwing that charge at the right and
it's usually the right throwing that
charge at the left
Elena Kagan is about to get on the
Supreme Court
how is she going to affect the makeup of
the court and the types of rulings it's
it's putting forth its you know it's
hard to tell because she's managed to
give a lot of non answers as all these
as all recent Supreme Court nominees do
I think it's very safe to say that she's
going to be a pretty consistent liberal
vote so as Solicitor General in the
Citizens United case Kagan argued on
behalf of defended the government's
position was in defense of the
mccain-feingold law and and since that
decision came down against her position
she said that you know she thought that
the court should have deferred more to
Congress so I think what we'll see with
her on the court and as brock obama's
policies are being challenged and
brought to the challenge before the
supreme court you're gonna see this
liberal block saying no no it's time to
defer to Congress it's time to practice
some judicial restraint judicial modesty
and we'll be using those arguments
against the Conservatives final question
you you've written a lot about kind of
libertarian judicial activism a lot of
which has to do with overturning
precedent what's what's the one thing
what's the one precedent what's the one
law that's going to come up around the
Supreme Court or has recently that needs
to be changed well I do think that
there's that the challenge under the
Commerce Clause to the Health Care Act
is is very strong that's gonna probably
that comes before the court that'll be
in a few years I think that would that's
a very good example of where we
shouldn't be deferring to Congress the
courts should be looking and strictly
scrutinizing the law in question as far
as recent Supreme Court precedents I'd
love to see the kilo decision thrown out
to the Gonzalez rage decision I think
those are horrible precedents should be
overturned why is the kilo decision so
bad I mean we both agree that eminent
domain abuse first off is abuse but all
you know is I mean it's not
constitutional per se but why does that
rise to a level that where it's more
execrable than you know everything
Congress does on a daily basis well the
Constitution says that private property
we can can be taken for a public use
with just compensation paid and and kilo
and some of the other eminent domain
cases in the courts line have expanded
public use to public purpose and civic
purpose so essentially it's one thing to
take land to build a road or a highway
or hospital even a zoo or something that
that's something that the public is
using it's over
to all now we're just seeing these
takings for you know sports stadiums
basically for the purpose just of
raising more tax money justice
O'Connor's dissent in kilo I thought was
very good where she said you know under
this standard any farm can be taken and
turned into a shopping mall and a you
know a hotel 6 can be taken for
ritz-carlton and so I think that's a
very dangerous very dangerous precedent
right thank you I'm Nicholas P for
reason TV we've been talking about Damon
route reason associate editor about his
cover story and the July issue of Reason
conservatives versus libertarians thanks
Damon thank you
you